a menos de dos semanas de las elecciones
presidenciales oficiales estadounidenses
acusan a irán de interferir en los
comicios con el fin de sembrar caos y
malestar social
hemos confirmado que algunos datos de
registro de votantes han sido obtenidos
por iran y por separado por rusia estos
datos pueden ser utilizados por actores
extranjeros para intentar comunicar
información falsa a los votantes
registrados con el objetivo de causar
confusión y caos y socavar su confianza
en la democracia estadounidense
el gobierno estadounidense acusó a irán
de estar detrás de una campaña de
correos electrónicos falsos dirigida a
los votantes demócratas de algunos
estados pendulares los emails parecían
venir del grupo de milicia armada ppd
voice los chicos orgullosos instando a
los destinatarios a votar por donald
trump según los funcionarios teherán
también está difundiendo un vídeo que
afirma falsamente que la gente podría
emitir un voto fraudulento desde el
extranjero un portavoz de la misión de
irán ante las naciones unidas
negó estas afirmaciones de
interferencias los servicios de
inteligencia de eeuu aseguraron que
rusia también había obtenido información
de los votantes pero no especificó que
planean buscó hacer con ella no es la
primera vez que una potencia extranjera
interfiere en las elecciones de eeuu en
2016 las agencias de inteligencia del
país concluyeron que unos hackers
apoyados por el crimen estaban detrás de
un esfuerzo para socavar la campaña de
hillary clinton
usando ciber ataques y noticias falsas
en las redes sociales trampa puesto en
duda repetidamente las afirmaciones este
miércoles los oficiales estadounidenses
dijeron a los ciudadanos que deberían
confiar en que su voto cuenta y
subrayaron que los sistemas electorales
seguían siendo seguros